[Musica]
ho ricevuto una mail una delle mille che
mi arrivano al giorno che mi spiegava le
origini del co bid cover è una scelta
che le grandi potenze hanno fatto per
coprire la fine del petrolio
durante il comic abbiamo visto c'è stato
bisogno di molto meno benzina petrolio e
quant'altro
perché è stato prodotto progettato così
serviva perché il petrolio è finito e la
società l'economia devono cambiare e per
cambiare ci voleva uno shock
ci voleva una cura che trasformasse il
sistema economico in un sistema che
consuma meno petrolio
perché il petrolio non c'è più non ce
l'hanno detto che non c'è più ma ci
hanno creato il compito per farci
cambiare abitudini in modo che siamo
diventati capaci di gestire un mondo
senza petrolio con pochissimo petrolio
petrolio che sta finendo
questa mail continua e scritta con
gentilezza e complicità mi conosce la
persona che me l'ha mandata al suo dire
mi ha seguito nel tempo e voleva
aiutarmi a comprendere che cosa sta
succedendo e non c'è solo questa storia
che spiega come ce ne sono migliaia che
circolano in rete
tutte storie che finalmente spiegano il
perché di questa sofferenza raccontano
una visione del mondo che la che in ci
insegna a convivere con questa
sofferenza e hanno una caratteristica in
comune non hanno niente a che fare con
fatti provati documentati sono
semplicemente delle storie che creano un
senso intorno a quello che sembra
succedere
dal 2016 stiamo parlando di fake news
come parte integrante del sistema della
democrazia o meglio della crisi della
democrazia ce ne stiamo lamentando
stiamo dicendo che le fake news non sono
solo le fake news c'è l'odio in rete c'è
la banalizzazione dei problemi c'è una
quantità di persone che parlano a
sproposito
stiamo distruggendo la democrazia con un
sistema di informazione che non funziona
bene
questa tesi è una tesi molto ripetuta è
stata è diventata molto popolare dal
2016 quando sono successe due grandi
fatti inattesi la vittoria del
referendum per la break sit e la
elezione alla presidenza americana di
donald trump
indubbiamente tra democrazia e il
sistema dell'informazione ci sono delle
relazioni significative
la democrazia non è soltanto andare a
votare
la democrazia è andare a votare in un
certo modo per esempio essendo informati
su come stanno le cose
se si va solo se la democrazia è
soltanto andare a votare
fondamentalmente era democratico anche
il sistema di saddam hussein ma la
differenza
il modo di andare a votare è la cosa più
importante se i cittadini sono informati
e ragionano sulla base di fatti
documentati
avranno delle scelte se ragionano in
base a narrative che non necessariamente
hanno a che fare con i fatti
prenderanno delle scelte diverse
il problema chiaramente non è quello di
lamentarsi delle fake news ce ne sono
sempre state problema non è quello di
lamentarsi dell'odio
c'è sempre stato e anzi forse in passato
dobbiamo dirlo era anche più pesante
quando certi persone in occidente
mandavano a morire certe altre persone
solo perché erano nate in uno di una
certa cultura o quando ragazzi
fondamentalisti italiani sparavano con
la pistola nelle gambe delle altre
persone avversari politici quello era
ovvio quello che c'è adesso è qualcosa
di diverso e una sorta di sofferenza
generalizzata della quale in qualche
modo dobbiamo saper sapere e convive con
la quale dobbiamo convivere quello che è
brutto quello che non funziona e la
manipolazione di questa sofferenza la
manipolazione della difficoltà a leggere
la realtà in modo semplice e visibile e
documentabile la difficoltà conoscere le
cose in modo che possa essere
comprensibile il ragionamento che
facciamo
dopo quelle cose la democrazia migliora
se le persone sanno come stanno le cose
democrazia peggiora se le persone vivono
in una bolla di narrativa che non ha a
che fare con i fatti come affrontare
tutto questo probabilmente noi ci siamo
preoccupati del modo con il quale si fa
informazione con una mentalità un po
antica cioè la mentalità nella quale uno
si dice l'informazione si fa in questo
modo la fanno i giornali la fanno le
autorità preposte
e quindi si sa come stanno le cose
c'è stato un grande movimento che ha
accolto l'opportunità di internet per
mettere in discussione questa sorta di
monopolio della verità che c'era una
volta ed è stato sostituito da un nuovo
modo con il quale si fa informazione che
non è più industriale lineare con un
sistema coerente con il mondo lineare
industriale del dopoguerra
siamo in un mondo nel quale
l'informazione assomiglia di più a un
ecosistema a un sistema complesso nel
quale tutto si connette con ogni altra
cosa i fenomeni coinvolgono le
piattaforme fanno vivere qualunque
genere di idea e emergono opinioni e
informazioni in modo non del tutto
prevedibile
siamo in una informazione che assomiglia
all'ecologia
contrastare cambiare fare evolvere
questa eco sistema dell'informazione è
possibile non è fattibile con metodi che
fanno pensare a un ritorno al passato è
fattibile pensando a sviluppare quello
che abbiamo conquistato fino adesso e
trasformarla in qualcosa di più
[Musica]
contemporanea di più orientato al futuro
quindi in qualche modo possiamo imparare
a gestire questa informazione come si
sta sviluppando oggi sui media digitali
con la stessa mentalità che abbiamo
sviluppato per conoscere l'ecosistema to
corre col sistema con il quale
conviviamo sul pianeta come abbiamo
imparato a fare quello che non abbiamo
ancora imparato molto bene per la verità
abbiamo imparato che l'ecosistema e
complesso che coinvolgono i fenomeni che
è bello un ecosistema nel quale c'è
biodiversità
quindi nel nostro caso info diversità
nel quale la ricchezza di informazioni
alimenta una energia positiva che va a
cercare qualità e questo è tutto
possibile come è possibile invece un
degrado dell'ecosistema una sorta di
monocultura una quale la l'unica
piattaforma funzionante gestisce tutto
il trasferimento di informazioni e
decide che cosa si può sapere che cosa
non si può sapere un ecosistema
limitante soffocante contro un
ecosistema ricco di diversità di una
fioritura di idee alternative nelle
quali effettivamente l'evoluzione spinge
verso una forma di qualità allora questo
è il momento nel quale siamo di fronte a
se c'è una cosa che possiamo fare è
creare nuove piattaforme che creino
nuove forme incentivanti nuove modalità
di convivenza maggiori diritti delle
persone nel governo e riguardi dei loro
dati e nei riguardi delle relazioni che
hanno
gli altri possiamo anche rinunciare a
questo perché è troppo difficile ma ho
l'impressione che sarebbe una scelta
assolutamente insensata e come dire
abbiamo inquinato il pianeta e dobbiamo
lasciare che peggiori sempre nel tempo
ho l'impressione che abbiamo la
possibilità di costruire una strategia
ecologica dei media per creare un
ecologia della democrazia è un lavoro
molto grosso da fare però se non
cominciamo non lo facciamo mai
[Applauso]
[Musica]